when the new Mac Mini came out in
October it made a lot of buzz because
Apple packed in much better hardware
than anyone was expecting the RAM is
once again user upgradeable even though
it's not easy and has a very impressive
4 Thunderbolt 3 ports the option for 10
Gigabit Ethernet and up to a 6 core i7
processor it was basically a Mac Mini
Pro the 6 core i7 CPU outperformed any
iMac back then since they were limited
to 4 cores and with the promise of
optimized EGP you support with
Mahavishnu prefer a GPU feature it was a
fantastic value and we'd still recommend
everyone to get the $1100 Mac Mini over
the $800 model because you get the 6
core CPU and a 256 gigabyte SSD which is
the least we'd recommend on any computer
and now that it's getting close to a
year later has the Mac Mini lived up to
the potential we first saw in it no and
I'll tell you exactly why in just a
minute there are a couple of things that
are really special about the Mac Mini
and the biggest thing is the extensive
variety of i/o with 4 Thunderbolt 3
ports two USB 3 ports the option of 10
Gigabit Ethernet and HDMI you literally
cannot get this much i/o on any other
Mac except for the $5,000 iMac pro it
even allows you to swap out the RAM
yourself and save about $550 on a 64
gigabyte kit compared to apples $1000 64
gigabyte ram upgrade by using the link
in the video description below the Mac
Mini packs a ton of performance for the
compact size and the most important
thing is that it runs Mac OS and will
continue to get Mac OS updates for free
for years to come and because of the
compact size you're definitely not
getting the full performance out of the
6 core CPU because it does throttle down
a bit compared to its potential in a
machine with better cooling but it still
performs very well the only major
downside of the Mac Mini is that it
doesn't pack a dedicated graphics chip
but that may not be a bad thing if
you're someone like a photographer or a
programmer who literally doesn't need
any extra graphics performance at all
but if you're looking to do some video
editing or 3d animation work you're
definitely going to want to hook up in a
GPU
we recommend the razor core X a GPU
enclosure with a Vegas 64 graphics card
for around $700 but you can definitely
buy an rx 580 in
and bring that down to around $500 in
our previous testing from a few months
ago we noticed that it shot graphics
performance through the roof so it seems
like an awesome deal for a very capable
machine we've recently got a new video
editor in our office and she's been
using a Mac Mini that we got in as a
loaner for a video as a temporary
editing setup because we already have
everything we need for it including a 4k
monitor a wireless mouse an old Apple
keyboard and an e GPU that we use for
previous videos however even though we
already have everything we need to make
this Mac Mini shine we'll be sending it
back and won't be getting another one
for long-term use here's why the iMac
has just been updated for 2019 and even
the 21 and a half inch 4k IMAX now come
with the same six core processors and
you can even get eight core iodine
processors on the MacBook Pros and 5k
IMAX and while it may seem like the Mac
Mini is a much better deal
now that the IMAX have been updated
everything that's bundled in for that
price makes it a much better value than
the Mac Mini even if you have to spend a
little bit more cash first off the Mac
Mini comes with nothing no mouse no
keyboard and no display while the iMac
comes with all of that that's $100 for
the keyboard $79 for the mouse and the
best part is the 5k display which is one
of the best displays you can find on the
market featuring incredible color
accuracy brightness and super sharp
resolution the standalone LG version of
that display was priced at $1300 so if
you add all of that up the iMac is a
much better deal and it comes with a
dedicated graphics card the problem with
getting an easy for you on the Mac Mini
is that you lose a lot of performance
efficiency because the data has to go
through the Thunderbolt 3 cable so a
much more powerful Vegas 64 graphics
card ends up not being that much faster
than the Radeon pro 5 ATX in the 5k iMac
now of course if you don't need graphics
performance the Mac Mini starts to make
a lot of sense but if you're a
photographer who's going to buy a very
color accurate for Cadis play for a few
hundred dollars
it actually makes more sense to just pay
five hundred dollars more to get a very
color accurate p3 display mouse keyboard
and five 60 X graphics which is what
comes in the $2,800 MacBook Pro now if
you're looking for a bit more
performance than that you can get the i7
6 core processor
512 gigabytes of SSD and if you already
have your own mouse keyboard and monitor
you'll spend $2,000 if you get an e GP
you with the RX 580 graphics and for
just $400 more you can get the top-end
5k iMac which comes with the peripherals
much better graphics performance due to
it being more efficient inside the
machine easy access to ram with double
the RAM slots and of course that
gorgeous and color accurate 5k display
and even if you spend more and get the
Vegas 64 graphics card in the e GPU in
many cases the 580 X graphics and the
iMac will perform just as well or even
better and you don't need to have a
large and loud box sitting on your desk
now if Apple upgraded the Mac Mini with
an 8 core processor or if a GPU
performance was better it would make a
lot more sense but at this time we would
honestly suggest almost everyone to just
save up a bit more cash and go for the
new iMac the experience will be much
better and you'll get more performance
for the cash now we told you that there
are a few cases where the Mac Mini still
makes a lot of sense the biggest one is
if you are using it as a server or in
other cases that you don't need to
display most of the time just a nice and
small computer the Mac Mini would be a
perfect option for this the second is if
you really need more than two
Thunderbolt 3 ports which you can't get
on the new iMac except for the iMac Pro
and along with that if you need 10
Gigabit Ethernet and you don't want to
use up one of your Thunderbolt 3 ports
for an adapter it's only a $100 option
on the Mac Mini and lastly the Mac Mini
makes sense if you don't need a good
graphics card save for photo editing or
coding and you already have a display
and peripherals that you want to use for
most people though even in this scenario
we would highly suggest giving the 4k or
5k iMac a shot it's seriously amazing
once you try it we've been using the 5k
iMac for years and we can't go back to
an average 4k monitor the Mac Mini isn't
a bad machine by any means and it still
has some good uses but almost a year
later it doesn't offer the same value
that it had it launched the processors
are no longer special considering that
the new MacBook Pro and 5k iMac now
offer eight core CPUs and a GPU
performance is nowhere near where we
thought it'd be we really hope that
Apple won't forget about this tiny
powerhouse and we'll keep updating it
with new processors and better cooling
but for now we think most people will
have a much better experience with an
iMac if you enjoyed this review make
sure
tap that like button click the circle
buff to subscribe and check out one of
those two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]